venera il 2012 io studiavo psicologia
alla bicocca di milano e come molti
universitari avevo finito per invertire
il mio ritmo sonno veglia stavo spesso
sveglio la notte
sprecato tanto tempo a guardare serie tv
a giocare videogiochi e in generale a
lottare con i miei pensieri
facciamo davvero fatica a concentrarmi e
mi ricordo che camminavo per ora è
avanti netto per la stanza nel tentativo
di riuscire a trovare la concentrazione
adatta per studiare e fu proprio in quel
periodo che successe qualcosa che ne
avrebbe cambiato la vita
vidi unanime in cartone animato
giapponese
che aveva protagonista un ragazzo di
nome stato che dopo essersi trasferita
dal suo paese di provincia nella grande
tokyo per studiare
aveva cominciato a sviluppare una
grandissima paura una fobia nei
confronti delle persone per lo sguardo
delle persone dei giudizi degli altri e
questa paura ossessiva lo aveva portato
piano piano a chiudersi sempre di più
finché non ha finito a vivere mesi e
anni all'interno del proprio monolocale
da solo senza più uscire
fu la prima volta che sentii la parola
hikikomori una parola appunto che
tradotto in italiano significa isolarsi
e mi folgorò perché io i tempi al
ragazzo molto timido anche avuto
difficoltà relazionali importante ho
subito bullismo in qualche modo anch'io
come come gli dico mori sentivo
quest'ansia costanza della prestazione
sociale questo bisogno di performare
quando si è con gli altri quindi da un
lato
rimasi scioccato dallo scoprire che
milioni di miei coetanei nel mondo
avevano scelto volontariamente di
passare tutta la propria vita da soli
chiusi in casa ma dall'altra in qualche
modo potevo comprenderle potevo capire
qual era il disagio che li aveva portati
a questa scelta terribile così decisi di
provare a studiare ad approfondire
perché mi interessava e quindi chiese la
mia professoressa di psicologia sociale
se potevo scrivere la tesi di laurea se
l'argomento lei non conosceva il
fenomeno ma mi diede fiducia e così io
passai successivi mesi a leggere tutta
la letteratura che c'era all'epoca era
soprattutto in inglese in giapponesi in
italia non c'era quasi nulla e scrissi
la tesi
ma anche lì non ero soddisfatto perché
dopo aver concluso la tesi sembrava che
tutto quello che avevo capito sarebbe
morto con me ma avevo l'esigenza di
comunicare parlare di questo tema
e così decisi di proprio una notte mi
ricordo erano le tre di notte di un
giorno di febbraio nel 2013 decisi da
per un blogger non ho mai fino a quel
momento fatto nulla online ormai ancora
fatto un video ma volevo appunto parlare
parlare di questo fenomeno e vedere
quanto fosse diffusa anche in italia
perché se ne parlava sempre come un
fenomeno giapponese non ho legato alla
cultura giapponese ma io l'ho convinto
anche per appunto affinità personali che
quel fenomeno fosse molto diffusa anche
in italia
ed effettivamente nei mesi successivi
all'apertura del blog cominciarono a
contattarmi dei ragazzi che vivevano in
una situazione di isolamento totale
che mi chiedevano non tanto aiuto ma mi
chiedevano di entrare in contatto tra di
loro che può sembrare sauna per
l'appunto sono ragazzi che scappano da
tutte le relazioni dagli amici dalla
scuola però volevano parlare perché
avevamo bisogno di questa socialità non
parlai con persone da cui non si
sentivano giudicati con persone che in
qualche modo avevano il loro stesso
problema e quindi deciso di creare
questa chat dove quel tempo affluire
centinaia di ragazzi e parlavano tutto
il giorno migliaia di messaggi
allo stesso tempo iniziarono a
contattarmi tantissimi genitori ancora
oggi otto richieste su 10 che ci
arrivano sono da parte di genitori con
figli in isolamento sociale i 100 erano
disperati sembravano ancora più
disperati dei figli stessi e volevano
aiuto ma io allora non ero ancora uno
psicologo e comunque non avrei potuto
far fronte a quell'urgenza da solo e
quindi decisi ancora una volta di creare
uno spazio online dedicato i genitori
dove coinvolgerli e dove potevano
incominciare a relazionarsi tra di loro
anche confrontarsi su quelli che
potevano essere gli errori o le
gli obiettivi comuni e proprio da quel
gruppo qualche anno successivamente
nacque l'associazione nazionale
chi sono gli dico mori sono spesso
ragazzi giovani tra i 15 e 25 anni i
ragazzi che appunto abbandonano la
scuola e lavoro gli amici e
cominciano a scappare da tutti gli occhi
da tutti gli occhi che sono fonti di
giudizio di pressione per loro che gli
ricordano che sono diversi che in
qualche modo differiscono dal modello
vincente della società
quindi sono di solito i ragazzi più
timidi più fragili
inibiti socialmente che non riescono a
alle gare con gli altri in classe che
subiscono bullismo che vengono isolati e
sviluppa nel loro questa forte
repulsione nei confronti della società
cominciano a vedere la società e le
relazioni umane come qualcosa di
profondamente negativo come qualcosa da
rifiutare si convincono che la loro vita
sia vivere da soli che stiano meglio da
soli
e che appunto siano destinati a questa
condizione
il problema che se inizialmente questa
questo isolamento può essere
effettivamente anche uno sgravio di
pressione con il tempo diventa una
trappola
perché più di chi come il rimane isolato
e più faticherà uscirne più
rimarrà in una condizione di incapacità
di reagire a questo isolamento infatti
il problema di tipo mori che non è quasi
mai una fase della vita quasi mai si
risolve spontaneamente da sola anzi
spesso tende a cronicizzarsi e a
diventare sempre più estremo con la
possibilità di rimanere in questa
condizione anche per tutta la vita non
sono rari i casi soprattutto in giappone
ma anche in italia di isolati da 20 30
40 anni che ormai sono finiti in questo
limbo e non sanno più come come tornare
indietro
sono ragazzi appunto che hanno spesso
interiorizzato forti pressioni dalla
società dai genitori magari hanno
famiglie che hanno avuto un grande
successo lavorativo scolastico e quindi
siccome anche culturalmente c'è un po
questa idea che i figli debbano sempre
superare i genitori che devono sempre
avere una una vita una carriera migliore
questa diventa una pressione diventa una
pressione che li porta
non riuscirà a reggere a questa costante
ansie che provano quando stanno con gli
altri
è un problema veramente gigantesco che
quando mi trovo a parlare perso in giro
per l'italia
insomma le persone vedo che sono
preoccupato ed effettivamente è qualcosa
che sono sicuro nei prossimi anni si
parlerà sempre di più perché è un
problema sommerso incredibilmente
diffuso probabilmente in italia ci sono
già centinaia di migliaia di casi però
allo stesso tempo non se ne parla perché
che rimane sotto traccia perché si fa
fatica a vedere
oltre a portarvi il problema cercare di
trasmettervi un po l'urgenza che che
vivo io sentendo queste storie vedendo
migliaia di famiglie che hanno questo
problema
vorrei darvi anche un po di speranza
raccontandovi una storia che ha avuto
quantomeno un aspetto positivo che mi ha
colpito
è la storia di davide un ragazzo che ha
12 anni si trasferisce dal suo paese nel
nord italia dove nato in un paese del
centro italia e li fa fatica enormemente
a legare con gli altri non riesce a
legare in classe un ragazzo chiuso
introverso
decide di abbandonare la scuola i
genitori provano con le buone e con le
cattive a convincerlo ma non ne vuole
sapere e a un certo punto
sopraggiunge l'impotenza e accettano
questa sua condizione ovviamente sempre
cercando soluzioni ma non trovandone
io davide lo conosco quando entra nella
chat cui vi ho parlato prima
è appunto lì mi racconta che lui dai 12
ai 19 anni non è mai uscito di casa a
parte rarissime eccezioni
per esempio quando sei innamorato di una
ragazza online e la forza di questo
sentimento l'ha spinto addirittura a
trovare il coraggio di uscire di
incontrarla
però per esempio davide non concepisce
l'amicizia
lui dice che è un sentimento che non
comprende e che non ha mai provato in
tutta la sua vita
a una passione però che nonostante tutto
nonostante anche l'apatia che questa
condizione sicuramente comporta riesce a
mantenere nel tempo e dalla passione per
il disegno non è mai riuscito a
concretizzarle in un lavoro però l'ha
sempre mantenuta e quando io vedo i suoi
disegni
mi viene un'idea vi propongo di
realizzare delle vignette per per i siti
della tep e degli articoli del sito
quindi io scrivo un articolo sul tema
delle tic omori su uno specifico
segmento di questo tema e lui realizza
una vignetta che che sia inerente
e facendo questo lavoro viene notato da
una giornalista che gli propone di fare
una mostra in un locale a milano lui
ripeto non usciva da sette anni quindi
contro ogni pronostico contro anni di
accetta di uscire di casa di andare a
milano e e io l'ho visto l'ho visto in
quel locale
mentre le persone gli chiedevano insomma
dei suoi disegni e gli facevano i
complimenti
l'ho visto era sicuramente una persona a
disagio che non aveva dimestichezza con
quell'ambiente però era felice era
felice e riusciva a stare con gli altri
allora in quel momento ho pensato ancora
di più mi sono convinto ancora di più
che
quando parliamo di kiko mori parliamo si
di un problema del singolo di un
problema psicologico molto profondo però
un problema che può essere superato
aiutando questi ragazzi aiutandoli
commesso città a trovare una motivazione
nella motivazione intrinseche alla vita
anche perché spesso questi ragazzi
perdono perdono
qualsivoglia obiettivo non sanno dove
andare non sanno quali quali strade per
seguire vivono anche una sorta di signor
esistenziale
e si perdono si perdono e le loro paure
diventano più forti di tutto nella loro
paura del giudizio allora paura di
essere diversi di non essere accettati
diventa talmente forte da spingerli a
nascondersi a nascondersi nella propria
stanza da letto e talvolta scappare
anche dai genitori parte ci sono casi di
ragazzi che nemmeno hanno contatti
diretti con i genitori
quindi ho pensato che è appunto questo
ragazzo che per sette anni non era
uscito in quel momento grazie a quello
stimolo a quella sua passione aveva
trovato la forza di uscire di casa di
affrontare le sue paure l'anzhi del
giudizio agli sguardi delle persone
e di
vivere sostanzialmente riuscire a vivere
la sua vita come quella di tutti gli
altri e quindi ancora una volta ripeto
ho pensato che è vero di kiko mori è un
problema psicologico del singolo va
aiutato va supportato però è anche un
problema
della società perché ognuno di noi in
qualche modo nel suo piccolo
contribuisce a creare questa società che
molti ragazzi sempre più ragazzi
percepiscono come eccessivamente
pressante eccessivamente competitiva
come una società respingente dai valori
lontani da quelli che hanno loro
e se appunto sempre più ragazzi sentono
questa questa sensazione provano questa
repulsione nei confronti di tutto il
resto
sicuramente dovremo fare anche una
riflessione collettiva tutti insieme
come societa e cercare di capire quali
sono le dinamiche sociali che creano
questa spaccatura questa spaccatura tra
persone che sono sempre più di successo
che riescono a utilizzare la
competizione sociale per eccellere e le
persone che invece crollano sotto questo
peso che non riescono più a reggere
queste aspettative e finiscono per
innescare un meccanismo del tutto niente
ora aggiungo l'obiettivo
l'obiettivo che io ho idealizzato quello
che io penso di poter valere che spesso
molto alto il realisticamente alto
oppure abbandono tutto smetto di giocare
mi siedo ai lati della strada mimì mi
chiudo nella mia camera e lì interrompo
la mia esistenza
quindi per chiudere
io sono convinto che
dell'iti comore ne sentiremo parlare
sempre di più perché è qualcosa che
cresce senza che nessuno di noi magari
se ne renda conto ma lo percepiamo che
che c'è e ogni volta che ne parlò
spuntano sempre nuovi casi
ma dobbiamo cercare tutti come società
dalla scuola la famiglia a ognuno di noi
interessarcene e di riuscire ad aiutare
questi ragazzi a tornare nella società
perché
creare una società inclusiva significa
anche questo aiutare a stare nella
società anche a quelle persone che
usciva fa sta nella società anche quelle
persone che sentono questa forte
pressione sulle loro diversità che sia
anche in questo caso appunto una
diversità caratteriale
quindi il mio pensiero con cui insomma
voglio chiudere queste terre che alla
fine di kiko mori ci riguarda tutti
[Musica]